gender specific care is very important
because if we reflect on where we are
today scientifically it's the era of the
potential of the genome it's the era of
quote unquote
the emergence of personalized medicine
and if we think about sex specific or
gender specific care and I just want to
be clear sex is who we are genetically
women have two x-chromosomes
men have an X and a Y and gender is how
we are responded to in society because
of our sex but if we think about this
era of the potential of science and we
think about the fact that men and women
are different biologically you know
every cell has a sex and that's the
phrase that the Institute of Medicine
coined the potential for the development
of science as we think about sex
differences is just enormous what it
means when we think about sex
differences in health and disease is
that men and women differ in every
aspect of health and disease and the
potential for discovery here is is
tremendous today we only are at the very
early stages of understanding what some
of those differences are from a clinical
standpoint and we are really have a long
way to go before we fully understand the
scientific base for some of those
differences so just to give you an
example if you look at a woman who has
heart disease or blockages and her
arteries or symptoms that make one think
she might have blockages in her arteries
we know that those symptoms differ
between men and women now that's a
clinical observation what we don't know
is why we see those differences in
symptoms then if you do testing in a man
or a woman the qualities of the test the
sensitivity and the specificity the
characteristics of the test differ
between men and women certain tests are
better in women than they are in men and
then
very interestingly when you actually
look at the type of disease women have
so what their arteries actually look
like the arteries can look different
and what we begin to understand is that
some of the gold standard tests that
we've been using for many years that are
based on the typical disease that men
have may not function as well in women
and so we've had many years of women
undergoing these tests and being told
that they are actually fine so today
we're in a different place we understand
that there are some of these differences
some of that knowledge is not as
generalized and as widely understood as
we need it what we don't understand is
biologically why do we see those
differences so as you can see there's
this cycle between
clinical observation science getting the
word out translation of that science to
clinical care and observation once again
feeding more science
I wouldn't say that there are specific
issues that are unique to women what I
would say is that there are issues that
are either more prevalent in women that
need to be focused on and some risks
that impact women differently so for
example if you look at diabetes for
reasons that we don't fully understand
the impact of diabetes on women's heart
health seems to be more profound than it
is in men so diabetes will wipe away
some of the early protection women have
against heart disease but women will be
more likely to die of cardiovascular
disease and then when you layer over
that some differences in for example
across racial and ethnic groups you see
some very stark differences for example
in african-american women compared with
white women with african-american women
having much higher rates of diabetes and
also having much higher rates at a very
early age of cardiovascular disease
another major health problem is
depression depression is more common in
women and it also seems as though
depression may be more linked to the
development of further events for the
coronary events when women already have
heart disease so once again differences
and the prevalence of disease and then
differences potentially in the impact on
outcomes in women
there are some newer technologies in the
area of Cardiology that I think are very
exciting for women so for example if we
look at the fact that women are more
likely to lay down plaque in their
arteries in a way that it is diffusely
laid down as opposed to there being a
very discrete blockage in the artery
that can be opened up for example with a
stent if women have that more diffuse
disease more frequently then it's hard
to see with our traditional tests which
is a cardiac catheterization newer
innovations with things like
intravascular ultrasound that allow us
to put a tiny ultrasound probe into the
artery and look at the artery almost
from the inside out that is a very
important development for for women in
particular not that every woman should
have it but for certain women for
example who might have a positive stress
test they get in the catheterization lab
the traditional test is done and there's
no answer this might be the appropriate
next step another exciting advancement
is the use of small wires that measure
flow throughout the artery if women are
more likely to have what we call micro
vascular disease disease and the tiny
arteries the small arteries coming off
the big ones once again that you can't
see with our gold standard tests then
once again for certain women for whom
the answer is not totally clear with
traditional tests this may be an option
and this is very important because it
allows us to make a diagnosis in an
important sub population of women and
quite frankly I think by thinking about
women and how they differ it will help
us look at all patients differently and
it's always my belief that by looking at
women and looking at the science and
translating that science into clinical
care we actually improve the health of
everybody because we begin really
thinking about what each and every
individual needs
appropriate to kind of the evidence